here we have koko the clown from bedtime
it's animated film from 1923 and you can
see that the animator has their hand in
the picture having a lot of fun
squashing and stretching koko the clown
and you'll discover from our workshop
that they use the same concept today as
they did then in the animated movies
that you love now so not much has
changed in 100 years although some
things have changed
hi everyone my name is Brooke Keesling I
am the director of animation talent
development at bento-box studios we make
shows like Bob's Burgers Duncanville
Central Park many others and my job is
to find talented artists like some of
you are and maybe someday when you work
in animation I'll be looking for you to
come work on some of our shows I've
recruited talent for Cartoon Network and
Disney and Warner Brothers and now I'm
at bento-box
my entry into the world of animation was
my dad owned a model train store when I
was a little kid it was in North
Hollywood California and a lot of his
customers were were animators at Disney
and hanna-barbera and local studios and
I was always sitting at his counter
drawing after school and one of them
said you know animation is a real job
you could you could do this for a living
someday and I I just had no idea how
that all works so hopefully Jorge and I
will shed some light on some of that for
you when I grew up I went to Cal arts
which is a school here in LA for
animation and one of my films that I
made while I was there called booby girl
when the student academy award and
that's how I got involved with the
Motion Picture Academy whom I love I
love their programming I love all the
things they do some of my favorite
things about animation are that you can
tell any kind of story there's no
limitations you can animate a puppet or
a drawing or a CG model or an object you
could animate the toys in my room so I
love animation so much it's I you know
eat sleep and breathe animation so I
hope that we can teach you a lot about
that today and that we inspire you and
then here's my co-host Jorge Gutierrez
hi you guys names for hick Gutierrez I
am originally from Mexico I created a
show with my wife at Nickelodeon called
El Tigre The Adventures of Manny Ribera
and then many years later we made a
movie called the book of life which came
out in 2014 hopefully a lot of you guys
were bored already by that point and I
fell in love with cartoons like a lot of
you as a little kid I
I you know there were my best friends
growing up the the animated movies and
and animated TV shows and it felt like
they loved me back so as I grew up I am
writing stories and I love drawing and a
family friend said you know that's
animation if you can make these drawings
moving you can tell these stories so
much like Brooke I also went to Cal arts
California Institute of the Arts and
then the my favorite thing about the
medium is that it's a combination of all
the arts music and acting and and
drawing and movement and dance like
they're all there so if you love the
arts animation is there for you and then
the other some thing about making
cartoons and and and making a living
doing this stuff is you don't have to
grow up you get to be a kid forever so
everybody you meet in animation we're
all professional children so thank you
guys for joining us and it will just
jump in so let's get started with our
first special guest here is the
oscar-winning director of up an inside
out and the chief creative officer of
Pixar Animation please welcome the one
and only dr. hi everybody I'm Pete
docter I'm a director at Pixar I did
Monsters Inc up inside out and soul
which we're hoping is gonna come out in
theaters just a few months November 20th
I was asked to come here and describe
animation and talk about flip books and
I'm here in my closet because there's
some kids playing outside and it's the
only place I could find it's relatively
quiet so what happened for me when I was
a kid
unlike the noisy kids outside I was a
pretty quiet kid I sat inside a lot and
somebody gave me a flip book I know if
you've seen these they're like basically
I made one recently I made a bunch when
I was a kid but my mom has all those so
this is one that I did in 2004 and you
can see basically there's me under the
mistletoe and I'm waiting for a kiss
from my wife
she walks right by then oh here come the
kids ah no kiss from them either look
there comes the dog and it's an
introduction of our new dog which we
just got at that time named Bailey so
the cool thing about these are though is
that it tells you can tell the whole
story you can get all set to cool
movement but basically it's just a bunch
of pieces of paper and each drawing is
just a little different than the last
one and when you flip through them it
creates the illusion of movement now the
thing is at Pixar we make computer
animated films but it's the same idea
it's basically just that we use
computers to help us to draw the
pictures but each one of them when you
watch a movie here's a little flip book
of Doug
there's Doug and he's excited about
getting the ball and then Carl throws it
so it's basically the same idea here
each image there's 24 of them every
second it's just a little bit different
than the last one so it's a great way if
you are interested in animation you can
get going on this right at home without
a lot of expensive equipment or
electronics or anything this is one that
my friend did when I gave him that flip
book and he just did this thank you and
you can make your own either grab like a
you know one of these notepads from like
a hotel oh you know what actually works
really well are those um 3m post-it
notes the yellow you know they have the
stickum on the top you can flip through
those that works really nice or you can
also just get one of these clips like
this and a bunch of either note cards or
just pieces of paper and let's I'm gonna
make one for you right now I'm just
gonna use these blank pieces of paper
I'm gonna draw a little picture on each
page and then when we're done we'll clip
it together like that and see how it
looks let's see I'm gonna move the
camera
okay so here I've just got all these
piece of paper and the nice thing is you
can do it drawing if you make a mistake
on one you can just get rid of it so it
works nicely I'm the the simplest thing
would just be like a bouncing ball so
here we'll start with a ball and what
you want to do is kind of be able to
imagine where that previous drawing is
because animation is really all about
like the movement from one frame to next
so here you can see it's kind of stand
in the same place I can hang there for
just a second
I'm gonna go down just a little the next
page and I'm gonna have it stretch out a
little bit because it's falling and then
smash smash on the ground let's imagine
the ground is about here
smooshes and then it's gonna kind of
come out of the smush and then bounce
back up into the air although maybe not
quite as high as it was before we hope
so let's see how that looks so you can
you can see very simple boring ball
bounce so let's try something a little
bit more complicated although still I
wanted to get too complicated because
you have to draw a ton of these drawing
so okay let's do something slightly more
complex this time let's start with a
person standing here and gonna be nice
and simple because we're going to draw a
lot of these you're gonna spend a lot of
time drawing each each image because
there's gonna be tons of these and then
when I think I'm gonna do is if the
character jump that way so to go that
way I first have to go the reverse so
well that's what we call anticipation so
if you try this yourself like if you're
gonna jump that direction you would you
do first you'd bend your knees right so
what's the next frame is going to be
kind of bending the butt back a little
and getting the knees bend slightly okay
and then go further with that heads down
even further the butts back further and
the knees are bent even more it's a
really bad drawing like that that's
awful but it doesn't matter because you
can throw it away and get another one
and it doesn't matter anyway because in
animation it's all about the movement
it's not about the individual drawings
they don't have to be really pretty it
can be pretty sloppy at least to start
out with and then maybe you go back and
make them look nicer later but okay so
now here you can see already this
character is starting to bend down let's
go even a little further with that so
push it push the extreme now he's really
she I don't know if this is a boy or
girl doesn't really matter he's really
bending down to get a lot of
anticipation so that we can really leap
off so then we're gonna hammer shoot out
from where they were like that and then
so that's gonna be the maximum thrust
and then after that we're gonna kind of
slow in just a little bit you know it
doesn't travel quite as far his frame in
the next frame bodies kind of catching
up maybe this leg stays back a little
further and that arm
okay in the next frame let's say this
knee is bending up nice but this one
we're gonna do kind of like a
follow-through like let's see how that
works
no I got two pieces of paper thing is
I'm not really sure where this is going
I didn't plan it out at all sometimes
it's kind of fun
he'll just see what what happens because
you know you go from one friend to
another and you're kind of like oh wait
a minute let's say in this frame you
know we can see this person didn't plan
very well for their jump there's time to
twist and fall over and now legs are
coming up this way let say this arms are
there and then the legs are falling down
okay then arm should probably got there
this is barely looks like a person
anymore but hopefully you get the idea
oh I forgot to add the face on those
other ones I can come back and do that
and let's just say that's where the
impact is and then you go splat on the
ground actually we should have a little
bit of the legs and arms kind of
quilling off the you know and then
landing now normally I'm just kind of
doing this to show you how animation
works but normally you'd want it's a
plane that's had a little bit better so
you have an idea of what it is you're
doing but let's see
okay so he jumps up whoop lands probably
heard it
whatever rework that a little bit but
you get the idea so from there it's just
a matter of making those drawings look a
little better here's a here's another
flip book that I did a couple of years
ago I spent a little more time on these
drawings you can tell so here's this one
is we're putting our stockings up
there's my wife and my daughter and
there's my son with a giant stocking and
my daughter says hey what the because
what because I have giant feet haha so
again you can see it's just each drawing
a little bit different than the last one
that's the trick and that's how you make
flip books that was a great gag yeah and
I get an extra stocking kids thanks so
much for that Pete that was great all
right you guys like Pete said you can
start with a stick figure and then go
back and draw in more details to your
characters so you can kind of rough it
out first and then go back and put all a
little you know little specific things
you want to put in there and speaking of
drawing characters it's time to put you
guys to work so grab your pencils or
pens or markers got a piece of paper and
we're excited to have a Hinman leave
join us from the Walt Disney Animation
Studios she's gonna show you how to draw
one of my favorite characters one of
your favorite characters one of
everyone's favorite characters from the
movies frozen and frozen - take it away
Hinman hello everybody my name is
heavenly and I'm an animator at the Walt
Disney Animation Studios I know it's
there this video screen but I'm really
happy to meet you all today and I'm
going to show you how to draw a very
friendly face and that's Olaf from
frozen so I hope you have a good time
watch
me draw hen but I hope you have even
more fun following along so let's get
started so for drawing Olaf we're gonna
use two pencils I'm gonna have a blue
pencil and a black pencil and the blue
pencil I'm just gonna use for some rough
guidelines so we can get his rough shape
and placement of his different parts so
with the blue pencil I'm gonna start
with a diamond shape and that's gonna be
his head and it's gonna be a diamond
shape that has like a flat top and
bottom so maybe on the top half of your
paper start with a diamond shape so it's
a diamond shape but with the bottom and
the top a little flat like that and with
this blue pencil just go really lightly
and rough you don't have to be very
exact they're gonna be line to can erase
later there can be like you can use a
different color pencil if you like but
they're just rough guidelines so in the
half point of that diamond just draw a
very very light faint line going
horizontally like that and so from the
top and that middle line in the middle
of those two then you can draw another
line and so right in that second line
that we drew that's gonna be a guideline
that's gonna help us place where his
eyes are gonna be so far his eyes we're
gonna draw nice little circles like
little ping-pong balls so right above
that line there draw one circle and
another circle
and next we're gonna have a rough
guideline for his nose his nice carrot
nose and it's gonna be starting right
under those eyes a little bit where the
bid middle of those two eyes are so draw
a nice rough cone shape and that's gonna
be his nose later and so that's it for
the rough guidelines for his head and
we're gonna draw his body parts now and
he has two parts for his body he's got
his chest piece and his belly piece and
they're both kind of like squashed
marshmallow shapes so I think
marshmallow but a little squashed
flatter version of it so here's the
little one for his chest and below it a
bigger one for his belly
so they're basically kind of like
rectangles but a little rounder version
of rectangles and under that belly we're
gonna draw his two feet and they're like
the little marshmallows they're the
smallest marshmallows so there's like
there's one foot and another foot
so that's about it for the guidelines
and still next what we're gonna do is
use the black pencil and start putting
in all the details so we're gonna start
with his eyes and right where we drew
those circles I'm gonna start with one
eye and start with a nice thick line for
the top part of his eye
and then you can finish that circle all
around and then same for the other I
start with a bit of a thicker line for
the top that's kind of like his eyelash
line and then finish the circle but
careful not to draw over where the
carrot is gonna be so you can leave that
part or if you did draw it then don't
worry about it you can always use an
eraser to erase it later after you draw
the carrot too so inside those circles
then now we're gonna draw in his pupils
and his pupils are gonna be nice too
little ovals and we're gonna draw them
on the right side of each circle and
that's gonna make him look like he's
looking right at us so here's one oval
and then here's the other one and if you
color them in nice and dark
yeah his eye is looking right at us so
now we have his eyes we can finish his
nose so right where we drew that rough
cone shape just draw a more detailed
carrot so start right between those eyes
right under them I can go over his his
far side a little bit sometimes you can
use add a little bit of a little crooked
shape there because it's a carrot
and if you look at carrots you can see
that they have these ridges running all
around them so you can draw this kind of
as these rounded lines all around all
down the carrot so there we have his
eyes and his carrot nose now I'll draw
his mouth and so for his upper lip Olaf
has a bit of an overbite which means his
his upper lip is like a little bit over
his lower lip and so for the start of
his upper lip we're gonna start drawing
a line under that carrot but a little
bit outside of the diamond guideline we
it so somewhere over here and then from
here you can draw this upper lip line
into a nice big smile
drop a speaker or a friendly smile and
then you can draw his the end of his
smile of a nice cheek corner and you can
add a little curve under his eye there
to just indicate a little bit of that
cheek pushing up against his eye and
under that lip line will draw his big
ice tooth there we have his and now we
can draw his eyebrows and eyebrows are
gonna go right over those two eyes so
we'll draw a nice little crescent shaped
eyebrows floating a little bit above his
two eyes there and now let's finish up
his head so start with the little line
that connects his eyebrow and his eyes
it's a horizontal line there and then go
over his eyebrows at the top of his head
and then you can connect it to that
diamond shape to finish the rest of
his headpiece Olaf's head and so to
finish up his head let's draw his little
hair quake so they're three little
sticks on this head there's they're kind
of like his hair it's one two and you
can draw little pieces of the stick like
little branches off of those and the
third one so you have this little head
head hair twigs
I guess so that's his hair and now we
can draw his body so let's go to that
small marshmallow finish up that chest
piece bottom marshmallow one things that
can be nice to do is to make the bottom
marshmallow get a little wider towards
the bottom that gives him a cuter shape
and so in those piece body pieces you
know he has this little cold button so
let's place them so think of it maybe
like if you put these in thirds I'm
going to use the blue pencil to help
still imagine dividing them into thirds
like that and so on the left side third
line you can draw one Kohl on the chest
and then two coals for the belly and the
coals can be just these nice jagged
shapes they don't have to be perfect
circles and you can color them in nice
and dark with the pencil like dark black
holes
and then we're gonna draw his feet so
his feet are the little marshmallows
right under his belly piece there
there's one foot and the other foot and
it looks like we're almost done but
we're missing something what are we
missing we're missing his arms so let's
draw his arms so let's see for the arms
we're gonna draw one arm first so
remember those two lines we drew for the
Third's
for the guide lines on the other side
we're gonna draw his other arm starting
so there's his shoulders and his arms
are basically two wooden sticks so
there's one coming down and then you can
draw his hand on the end of that stick
with this thumb and three fingers can
shade it in a little dark and for his
other arm I'm gonna draw it on this side
but draw it a little bit diagonally in
this direction you'll see why I'm doing
that as I draw it so draw another stick
and with this arm if we draw it this
direction what we can do is as we draw
his fingers and his hand
you can draw his fingers a little bit
more spread apart and what that does is
it'll make him look like he's waving at
us and she did a nice and dark and so
there we have Olaf waving his little
hand at us hello and as a bonus if you
do have one it's okay if you don't but
if you do have an orange pencil you can
always go in and color in that carrot
nice bright orange
so there you have it there's a lot so I
hope you had a great time following
along and I hope you have a wonderful
day and it was very nice meeting you all
so bye-bye I think I drew it wrong mine
looks like barbapapa
to everybody watching we can't wait to
see your versions of Olaf we're about to
jump into storyboarding so storyboarding
is kind of figuring out the movie in
drawings almost like a moving comic
strip and that way the directors and all
the artists can tell if the movie
starting to work or if it's not working
and and it's done in a way where it's
really fast because if things don't work
you can just throw it away and start
over and it hasn't gotten to the more
crazy expensive part of making the movie
so storyboarding is kind of like when
you sketch and you're just thinking of
ideas storyboarding is that for movies
before we can learn how to storyboard we
have a very special guest
he's the Oscar award-winning co-director
of spider-man into the spider-verse a
wonderful guy we both love him his name
is Peter Ramsey
take it away Peter hey everybody it is
great to be here and to share our love
of animation with you and for me my love
of animation started when I was just a
really young kid you know I love comic
books like spider-man of course and
movies like Star Wars and I really love
just taking a piece of paper and a pen
or a pencil and just start scribbling
and drawing little characters and making
up stories just to entertain myself I
didn't know it back then but I was
already creating art and learning how to
tell stories and that's what we do we're
storytellers even though I grew up here
in Los Angeles just a stone's throw from
Hollywood I had no idea that one day I
could get a job doing just that but
that's what happened through doing and
studying the things that I loved
before I became a director I started as
a storyboard artist turning the words in
a script into visual images and a story
a lot like a comic book and you're gonna
learn more about how we do that in just
a moment from my friend Miguel harem but
before I go I just want to say that I
hope today we can inspire you to find
something that interests you and moves
you and that can we can encourage you to
keep doing it draw lots of pictures
write stories make music or funny videos
whatever it is you love just keep on
doing it and remember you have the power
to create magic through your imagination
and now I'm gonna turn you over to my
very talented friend Miguel Haroon who
is a head of story at Sony Pictures
animation and who was our story artist
on spider-verse so over to you amigo hi
everyone my name is Miguel Verona and
I'm really excited to talk to you today
about what I do which is working as a
storyboard artist at Sony Pictures
animation most recently I worked on a
movie you might have seen called
spider-man into the spider verse which
is one of my favorite films I've ever
been a part of after working on
spider-verse I actually went on to
direct an animated short film which
featured my favorite character from the
movie spider game it's called spider-ham
cop mayhem and I also drew all the
storyboards in the short film as well
today I'm going to give you a little
behind-the-scenes look at making the
short and explain more about what
storyboarding actually is so what is
storyboard storyboarding is a visual
representation of a film sequence the
sort of blueprint or roadmap of how a
scene will feel look and play out in
time as a storyboard artist I take the
script or outline or sometimes even just
a description and I will draw out
hundreds of drawings that will define
the Civet ography it's a pace the rhythm
the acting and even the writing fighting
areas or I can enhance the emotion or
add jokes essentially I'm drawing out a
rough version of the scene that will
ultimately go to an editor who will
string all those hundreds of drawings in
order along with sound this way we can
workshop scenes and find out the best
way to film any given moment before we
add
hundreds of animators lighters modelers
on to the sea it's a safe place to
explore and find ways to make the scene
as best as it possibly can be to report
artists have to wear lighthouse your
part director part writer part summit
Agra fur predator part animator and your
even part showman sometimes picture your
scene in front of tons of people in a
room it's super fun but also super
difficult job as you can imagine you're
constantly exploring coming up with
ideas to make things better funnier more
engaging and more emotional for me as
far as it is it's the most fun part of
the process you're always throwing ideas
on the wall and seeing what sticks and
you're the first attack well how a scene
will play out cinematically which is
kind of a great opportunity
you're only bound by your imagination
when you can draw and it's incredibly
gratifying to craft aceton from the
ground down and that in a nutshell is
what I do as a storyboard artist so
here's a few visuals to show you some of
the early drawings we did spider-ham for
the short here you'll see some beautiful
drawings from craig mccracken a lot of
people the Titmouse team who helped us
animate the short
spider-ham cotta ham was such a love
letter an amazing opportunity to make
the best homage to the golden era of
looney tunes the classic cartoons that i
grew up with that i was obsessed with
and still am so it was a lot of fun
exploring the visuals and the character
explorations and making this the
ultimate cartoon starring our beloved
spider-man and here's a small
demonstration of how we utilize these
types of drawings to create a sequence
and tell the story this is a villain
from the short doctor Crawdaddy
getting ninja starred in the eye and you
can just tell from these really simple
three drawings that we're establishing a
closet effect right
spider-ham is grabbing the star dr. cry
daddy is looking what's happening and
then getting a ninja star in the eye
essentially this is any joke boiled down
to his essence it's the setup it's the
action and it's the reaction so now when
you put all the order drawings together
you can see that it becomes a moving
sequence and you know I love this movie
you're watching right now
because it so clearly illustrates how
much of a roadmap and blueprint
storyboards ultimately can be you know
when we were making this short we wanted
to make sure that we were super direct
and super clear with what we expected
for the animators and everybody else
involved in the short to follow and as
you can see we kind of stuck with it
pretty closely whatever happens in the
storyboard is what you ultimately will
see on screen so now that you've seen a
little bit of what storyboarding is and
how we use drawings to tell the story I
love for you to try it out with me I'm
going to take you through a quick
demonstrations of three different types
of shots we use all the time when we're
drawing and then give you a chance to
try feel free to grab whatever materials
you like best piece of paper pen
notebook whatever and while you do that
I'll get my screen set up as well all
right so I'm going to step through three
super classic camera setups that we use
in filmmaking all the time it's kind of
like our bread-and-butter foundational
type of shots the first shot I'm just
going to write it down is the
establishing stop the medium shot and
the close-up the establishing shot is
sort of like your showcases exactly
where this scene is settled so for in a
case of spider-ham cotton ahi'm most of
it nests up in dr. crawdaddies you will
there that's totally nondescript and
part of the city I'm drawing the city
skyline super rough lease for crudely so
you get just the basic idea right and
the biggest thing about storyboarding
oftentimes is clarity right because
they're lost than you're lost you know
so establish thoughts very basic very
simple to show us where we are
they are great a medium shot is sort of
like your classic shot of your
characters often filmed from the waist
up so classic medium shot again the idea
of a medium shot you're just showing the
character what they're doing it's
perhaps not the most emotional or the
most intense part of the sequence it's
just your classic set up to be like okay
we're focusing on this character and
here here
is doing what we need to see them doing
and so for our last shot the close up we
often employ close-ups for the more
emotional and more intense part of the
shots because this is where we really
want to be in the character with the
character rights so you know this
probably would be a little bit of an
extreme closeup and again you know this
is not necessarily about coming up with
the best most beautiful drawing I have
to say that right now it's about getting
clarity close-ups are what you want to
use when you absolutely want to make
sure the audience is in the character's
head and here you work these are kind of
the three again you know there's many
variations of these shots and many more
as you start thinking as a filmmaker and
I encourage you when you're watching
movies to start thinking like a
filmmaker seeing what sort of shots
there are what they're using and why
they're using it these are just simple
kind of the basic shots that we kind of
build as in photography and filmmaking
language from establish OTT and medium
in close-up and I hope this is just the
beginning of your journey and exploring
you as a filmmaker yourself so that's a
short demonstration of the type of
elements that storyboard artists keep in
mind when creating movie sequence if
drawing something that you enjoy
I would totally encourage you to keep
practicing drawing different characters
and even using storyboards to create
your own stories you can share with
others I'm glad I got to share a little
part of my time working on spider-verse
with you and thank you all for following
along today that was pretty amazing
right he's so great I mean that that you
know you don't have to make a movie to
use that language he just talked about
that you can use in your own comics if
you just draw comics for your friends
and you know notes that you pass them
during class oh wait you're not supposed
to do that don't forget you can watch
the entire short spider-ham plus a lot
of really cool extras about animation on
Oscars org click events and choose
family day the art of animation the word
animate means to bring something to life
that is not alive so if you're animating
a drawing you're giving that draw
if you're Anning animating a puppet
you're giving that puppet life but those
characters have to also live in a world
and the production designer gets to pick
the the colors and the costume design
and what the world looks like is it
pretty is it dark is it bright is it
sunny is it whatever whatever all of
those things are that's where the
production designer gets together with
their team and they work to make
everything magical and pretty for you to
watch in your animated movie and to tell
us more about it we have the amazingly
talented Kendall Cronkite and Priscilla
Wong from trolls they were responsible
for creating the handmade feel of the
whole movie Kendall and Priscilla are
going to tell us how they created all
these magical worlds over to you Kendall
hi everyone my name is Kendall Cronkite
and I'm a production designer in feature
animation I started my career as a
freshman illustrator on Tim Burton's
Nightmare Before Christmas and realized
once I got in that not only could I draw
paint like I always did and illustrate
like I always did but I could sculpt
models and build them out of foam core
and work with the model shop and the set
builders on the sets and I really got a
sort of full education on what it meant
to be a designer
in the animated world so I went from
Nightmare and then went on to James and
the Giant Peach as an art director and
did that for about two and a half years
before I started at DreamWorks there was
this new thing happening in AI donation
at that time and it was computer
graphics animation so when I started at
DreamWorks I actually started there on
ants as an art director I actually
didn't even own a computer
so when I first came in I said do you
guys want me to design for a computer
and the director said no we want you to
design what's best for the movie and
then we'll figure out how to make it in
the computer and that's been kind of a
mantra for me ever since I've stayed in
computer graphic animation with drew
marks since then so it's been about 24
years and then I went on to production
design Madagascar one two and three and
then trolls and trolls worlds who are
after that I think one of the great
things about bringing a production
designer you're involved in so many
aspects of the filmmaking you oversee
the art department so I usually have a
group of artists that are made up of
visual development artists that draw on
paint set designers that work in CG and
3d and character designers as well I
work really closely with the art
director in all aspects of designing the
film and together with the VFX soup we
then oversee all the departments
responsible for actually building the
film in modeling surfacing which is
creating all the surface textures and
whether it's glass or metal or bark or
wood we work with them on what that
should look like skin for characters
hair all of that and then we also work
with effects we work with the set
dressers and we actually oversee the
lighting on trolls we worked really
closely with one of our Vista artists
Priscilla Wong who really embraced
scrapbooking and she did it all
practically and I'm gonna hand it over
to her now to talk a little bit about
her process hi I'm Krystal Wong and I'm
the scrapbook artist on trolls my work
as a scrapbook artist involves drawing
painting cutting sewing and animating
sound waves when I first started out in
animation I didn't know where I'd fit in
only with Kendall what I got to work on
practical art on a 3d film thanks
Priscilla
so after trolls won we went
two trolls world tour for trolls world
tour we had many environments based on
musical genres and also tied it into our
trolls aesthetic which was kind of wacky
and based on fiber so we had our pop
trolls in pop village that were from the
first movie we had country-western
trolls in London flats in western one
road town all created with quilts and
the characters are part troll part horse
we had classical trolls little flying
boots arts and their world is like Machu
Picchu but cover it in rokoko
fabrics and lots of brocaded trends and
then funk is in a spaceship loosely
based on George Clinton's Parliament and
they would always have a spaceship
onstage and inside it's basically like a
lava lamp coming to life it feels that
way and there's a lot of instruments but
it's all made out of shag and metallics
and a lot of statins and crushed Velvets
which we felt really suited funk well
and we had Hard Rock trolls
and hard rock is denim and leather with
a little animal print thrown in we also
have a lot of studs and zippers in hard
rock which was really fun all the
graffiti and hard rock is embroidered
kind of like a jean jacket from the 70s
and hard rock was a volcano so all our
lava was like silk and ribbons of
glitter and the world of techno is
underwater and it's based on EDM
nightclub in a coral reef the idea kind
of came from what's water related and
fibre related and we came up with this
nautical knot idea and macrame is a
series of not making so it's all built
out of macrame and weaving with if you
imagine kind of fiber optics woven
through it and a lot of laser light
and our trolls are Murrells troll and
mermaid and they glow so that's just a
quick look at some of the work that I've
done as a production designer in
animation I hope it inspires all you
young filmmakers out there who want to
get involved in animation it's an
amazing amazing profession I feel very
very fortunate to be able to draw and
paint and design all day and collaborate
with filmmakers and artists that are
amazingly talented so join us we would
love that thanks a lot see you soon see
you at the studio wow that was amazing
thank you so much Priscilla and Kendall
that was incredible it made me want to
start cutting things up in my studio and
just building things you know I want a
glue gun and some googly eyes right now
[Laughter]
music is super important animation
especially since a lot of animated
movies are musicals and music can also
convey emotions sometimes it's really
hard to say something and you hear just
enough for music and you know exactly
how the characters feel and it's another
weapon to communicate and and and really
really skill the composers and musicians
and sound designers everybody works
together like an orchestra to make these
movies sound the way they sound it
really is incredibly important just try
to watch an any movie and turn off the
sound to see what I be true and then if
you want if you're listening to the
soundtrack later and you're not watching
the movie anymore because you're
listening to the soundtrack you can see
those visuals in your mind later so they
kind of work hand in hand in hand that
way our next guest is the oscar-winning
composer who's written the music for so
many animated films you've definitely
heard his music he wrote the music for
up ratatouille zootopia coco and inside
out let's all welcome Michael Giacchino
and it looks like you have a very
special guest with you Michael
[Applause]
everyone Michael chiquinho and this is
my son griffey chiquinho nice to see you
all normally we would do this talk in
person in a nice amphitheater over at
the Academy building but we're doing
things differently this year so we're
all gonna be at home watching and I
think what I'm here to do is talk a
little bit about music for animated
films you know normally when I'm writing
music I'll have an entire orchestra in
front of me to perform it so I don't
really have an orchestra with me right
now to demonstrate any of that and I
doubt you have one at home either so
what we're going to do is find some just
weird objects around the house that we
can use to maybe make some music with
now these actually are some things that
I have used in the films that I've
worked on
we'll start with this right here griffey
do you want to explain what this is
sure so this is what we call the Grif
sticks we found a lot of years ago and I
just got all the parts and just it
sounded enough like it could be an
instrument so it wasn't one of the
percussionist and in the orchestra's
name is Anil Richards he encouraged him
because once you make something and then
we can use it on the I'll play it with
you on the score so we went to Home
Depot and Griffey found these big bolts
and he also found all these washers like
I think we could put these together and
do you remember how you played them on
that on the score yeah just like that
but anyway they make a great sound and
you can just make it from things you
have at home these are just big bolts
and washers let's see what else we have
this what is this ball we know you have
a mixing bowl at home that's for sure
and mixing bowl can be used in many
different ways and it makes a lot of go
find a ball or something in the house
that you can use and you can hit it with
something soft like a piece of
would with a cloth over it or this is
just a little spoon that works as well
too so speaking of the spoon we have
some just random pieces of metal here
they're just pieces of metal that are
used and you can use any kind of metal
you can use tin cans you can use things
that you find in the garage old nails
maybe old whatever's just you know old
tools actually like an old wrench it
might be cool to to hit with this as
well so you'll have to do some
experimentation but the point is you can
use them in a variety of ways let's see
makes a lot of different sounds right
yeah and then each one has their own
sort of tone you're right all right so
that's cool and then we have this is
kind of crazy this is just a long spring
attached to a cardboard tube you're like
it sounds like a symbol but then when I
was showing it to Griffey he was like oh
wait let me try something with that
that's a cool sound so you can record
that and then these are just these
wooden pieces that my daughter painted
and made for me years ago I think for
Father's Day and I have been using them
on Star Trek and so this is how they
sound so if you know this work from Star
Trek at the very beginning the first
thing you hear is this and that's that's
what you hear in the score are these
right here
so again pieces of wood that you could
find around the house or hold you all
might work is like a wooden spoon from
the kitchen that would probably be
perfect a couple of those you could hit
against each other it'd be great so
we're gonna wait let's not forget that
you probably don't have this at home but
in case you do maybe you can make your
own version of this with some sort of
like plastic trumpet or a plastic maybe
a funnel or something like that again
again the garage is gonna be your
treasure trove for what to do here
what's this sound like yes that could be
very useful when creating a something
for an animated film so we're gonna run
through all of those real quick I'm
gonna try and get a closer shot so that
you can see them better
ah all right well now that we know we
have let's see we can do with it are you
up for trying to make something with
those sounds all right well there you
have it instant music from things made
around the house now get out there to
your house go look for things that you
can use to be creative with it make some
music make sure you ask your parents
versus probably a good idea but that was
fun what you think is right well thank
you so much for watching
[Music]
they'll probably never win Oscars for
music we're trying our McCheese is like
so saying is that animation is acting on
paper right I don't know if you've ever
heard that but there one thing we
haven't talked about yet is the voice
actors you want all of your cartoon
characters and animated characters to
say things to each other and and so we
find really amazing actors from all over
the world to do the voice acting
they usually have like really distinct
voices they can do funny voices are very
recognizable and if you can hear their
voice and see their picture without
seeing the actual picture then they've
done their job really well so what do
you want to say about voice acting or
hey you know it's a it's where the
characters really come alive a lot of
the times will record the actors first
most of the times we record the actors
first and then the animators draw based
on those performances it really is a
team of people coming together to make
these characters come alive and if you
like doing voices you know there's a lot
of there's actual jobs for kids to uh to
do voices because adults can never sound
as good as the kid voice acting it's a
busy so to hear more about voicing
unforgettable animated characters we are
switching over to Paris all the way in
France where we're going to meet the
incredibly talented Pierre caffeine and
learn how to talk like a minion Pierre
is not only the voice of the minions
like all of them but also the
oscar-nominated co-director of the skip
the despicable Me movies and minions
[Music]
hello everyone do you see the Eiffel
Tower way over there uh-huh well that's
because we're in Paris France and I'm
Kirk often I'm one of the directors of
the three despicable means one minion
but I'm also the voice of the minions
and
I'm gonna show you today how it is I do
what I do
let's get to it so it always starts off
with an idea and today I chose to tell
you a story where Stuart is gonna play
the ukulele and Otto is gonna give him
some advice
Otto is this new character we have in
our upcoming movie the rise of GRU he's
really nice but talks a lot and also he
has braces which give them this little
lift when he talks so he's going to try
and help Stuart by giving him notes and
notes and notes and notes and no - no -
no - notes until Stuart is gonna lose it
and hit him over the head with his
ukulele to make him stop and you would
think that Otto would be hurt by this
lack of love but no in the end he's
going to hum the song exactly like he
wanted it so what you're seeing here are
just like very very rough thumbnails
telling that story and what I'm gonna do
next is take those individual drawings
put them each other certain timing and
add dialogue and some singing to the
whole thing
okay so recording take one okay so it
parameter car Papageno poor I mean I
chose tacos enchiladas pero pero McKee
tuna karaage okay go okay Stuart poor
Amity Cup Papageno poem in that sauce
tacos enchiladas pillow pillow market
una Nicaragua okay okay okay
put anything up Papageno peanut sauce
tacos enchiladas pillow pillow
particular you got it okay
[Music]
okay so what I need now is lyrics okay
por la que no te ha Bharani por aqui no
tika Cunha - puh-lease nota
cool ami ba na na okay sorry for the bad
lyrics go
[Music]
oh okay why not and that's here back in
real time okay so now I'm gonna continue
writing words for Otto and so and so
after having done those thumbnails after
having written those weird dialogues and
played badly the ukulele
I usually go and use this software
called blender it's a 3d animation
software which has a 2d traditional
animation module inside of it
in short you can make your drawings come
to life blender is really really awesome
and incredibly fun to use and it's
totally free what you're about to see
now is not fully finished but it's you
when I give my animators as reference
for what they need to animate so it's
more about the over details that's what
I do I hope you found all that
interesting and I hope some of you will
be inspired to do their own stuff
doodling editing animating and and doing
the voices is all great fun so thank you
for watching and have a great day and
please please please stay safe the
program he used is free you guys it's
called blender so obviously ask your
parents permission but you can install
it and you can start doing what he did
and it doesn't cost anything which is
really cool so now it's time for the
kids who attended our workshop to create
a brand new character with Jorge oh I
see many of you hi everyone how are you
guys oh thanks for watching this this is
really fun yeah okay alright so what do
we got what's our first suggestion do
you guys see one for us Katie apparently
is able to tell us what it's Katie want
[Music]
what do you want fire
fired yeah yes let's do it let's do you
know what let's do a character the hats
fire for her release whoo fire lady it's
fire everywhere love this fire character
that was a good idea Katie that's
awesome idea and then I'm gonna add some
some color just to make it look more
like fire okay our next person who wants
to give a suggestion as nez le where's
Miss Ellie
renessa Li can you draw a bunny and a
bunny all right
miron lady likes her bunny and a bunny
can be looking at the at the fire lady
you guys get to boss around a famous
animation director this is amazing on
fire so after after it gets through with
a little bit more bunny Robin Dee is
gonna be the next person to give us a
suggestion so Robin Dee if you can
unmute and tell us what you want to be
added to this scenario ice and water all
right
no ice comes water comes out of his
pants and ice comes out of his head
[Music]
here's a guy and he's worried and he's
coming and just like she's made out of a
fire he's gonna be made out of ice I
really he's worried about the lady being
on fire well she's not I mean that a
fighter but she has fire for her so then
water is coming out of him okay well
Jorge's doing this Liana is our next
person who gets to give a suggestion
Liana do you want to unmute yourself and
say what you would like you can add to
these characters give a suggestion about
them or you can throw some other can you
troll sorry why don't we make this lady
so she'll have wings so she's a fire
fairy and there's a hand tiny little
legs she'll be holding along this is a
game you can play with each other you
know at home where one person draws the
head and then the next person draws the
body and the next person colours them in
you know you can kind of create a
character together with your friends or
siblings so our next person is Sebastian
Sebastian are you able to unmute and add
to the conversation say yes what do you
add a tiger alright here you go
Tigers are the best
Tigers are the best let me move these
guys over because we're study and now a
tie here is gonna show up Tigers looking
from this side
[Music]
the Tigers freaking out like he's good
make sure he has ears a little stripes
[Music]
and then we don't see his super hard to
draw a body but we see his tail we know
he's a tiger and yeah its whiskers its
fur we can color him orange so when you
guys are drawing you don't have to worry
about stuff looking super clean it's
more about having fun and they sure that
your uh thank you yeah thank you all so
much for that and thank you Jorge that
was really great so that was wonderful
we got lots of great ideas and we've
also been getting a lot of great
questions
Jordan nine of Palms California
but how can I break into the business
I'm artistic
that's great Jordan we love that you're
artistic Jorge do you want to start with
answering that question how to break
into the business
well becoming an animator or going into
into making cartoons it's just like any
other job in that most people have to go
to school so after you you graduate from
high school a lot of people either take
internet classes or they go to film
schools or they can go to sort of art
school and then move on to animation
school or go to a regular College like a
community college and then work their
way into a film score or cartoon school
and so if you love cartoons as a kid you
can take that love and and basically
train to do this for a living but it's
just like with anything in life the
harder you work at it the better it'll
be for you and and cartoons we always
say it takes a thousand drawings to do
one good drawing so draw draw draw as
much as you can and I you know that is
the way to do it and right now because
you're pretty young just draw wherever
you can you're obviously not able to go
to college at this moment but I know
that around Los Angeles and other cities
all over the United States and all over
the world there's places where you can
learn to draw like do life drawing at
you know you could go draw the animals
at the zoo draw yourself in the mirror
draw your feet draw your hands just draw
anything you can to really get that
visual language going because everyone
needs to learn those basics so once
you're a little bit older you can break
into the business our next question is
from Willa who's 11 Willa lives in Los
Angeles Willa are you going to unmute
and ask your question or I can read your
question for you you can read my
question okay Willa how many versions of
an animated character do you typically
go through before you have a finalized
character that's a really good question
there's there's many iterations right
where hey yeah I mean a lot of times
it's like figuring out what your
gonna eat right so you go mmm do I want
to eat this do I want to eat that last
time I this you know it wasn't as good
so you start crying to remember other
movies and other characters because you
don't want to design or come up with a
character that's too similar to movies
they have to be different but at the
same time it's really good to think
about why you love certain characters
and what made you sort of fall in love
with them or or laugh at them it's a mix
you want things to be new but also a
little bit familiar and especially with
characters it's always super super good
to base them on people you know so they
can be based on you or it can be based
on your brothers and sisters or your
parents or your friends or you know the
cafeteria lady that you don't like or
your favorite teacher and and and then
and then these characters start to have
sort of their own personality and so
instead of just making a funny drawing
or a pretty drawing you start having
character and that's super super
important if you notice sometimes when
you watch your favorite shows your
characters the characters can change
sometimes they evolve sometimes from the
first season of that show they might
have new qualities and new
characteristics by the third or fourth
or fifth season of that show so
sometimes the characters evolve in ways
that you know that the artists didn't
even expect it to so if you have
characters that you like to draw just
keep drawing them and draw them in
different scenarios you know draw them
as a you know in outer space and draw
them as a cowboy or a cowgirl and draw
them in all sorts of scenarios our next
question is from Ella what is your
favorite type of technology that you use
to animate your characters I now mostly
draw on the computer I used to draw on
paper all the time so I love drawing it
on a computer because like I mentioned
earlier it allowed me to try a bunch of
things and not worry about running out
of paper or ink so I use these drawing
tablets and you can do it on an
pad or you can do it on a Cintiq but it
allows you to be able to draw anywhere
which is really really cool and for
animation what the thing that I started
using was called flash and now it's
called Adobe animate yeah and it's a
really easy way to sort of jump in and
make little cartoons so I always
encourage kids if again if your parents
allow it yeah they'll be animate and if
you don't you know if you don't want to
get that like we mentioned earlier you
can also get blender which is free
there's all sorts of inexpensive
programs I know a lot of people like to
use procreate to draw procreate is not
very expensive
iStopMotion I think is still one that
you can get like to do a little
stop-motion like you could animate
things on your desk or on the floor your
Lego or whatever so there's all sorts of
technology technology always changes
it's really always about the ideas and
your own personal point of view as an
artist so that's that's the main thing
that you have going for you as an artist
so as you grow and develop your style
keep drawing and keep developing your
own style and learn from other artists
and and you'll keep on the right track
our next person is Anderson who's 5 from
Culver City Anderson do you want to ask
your question I you don't want to I'll
do it for you Anderson's question is
what is your favorite thing to draw my
favorite favorite favorite thing to draw
and if you have seen the book of life
you'll probably figure it out but I love
drawing skulls
he's called sad skulls angry skulls
confused skulls I don't know why ever
since I was a kid I really look forward
to Halloween and and Day of the Dead de
los Muertos and I've always loved
drawing skulls for some reason now I'm
working on a thing where the bad guy has
over 600 skulls on him so just you wait
yes my favorite thing what about you
Brooke I like drawing what is called
anthropomorphised food which just means
that it's food that's turned into
characters like like a cheeseburger with
eyes on it like I have behind me I think
it's really funny to make food into a
character so it that's one of my
favorite things to draw when I was
little I liked drawing Wonder Woman I
was the person in my school who was best
at drawing Wonder Woman so I drew Wonder
Woman all my friends notebooks Elaine
and Joe Villa 13 years old and guessing
twins the question is how do you pick
your voice actors we work with people
who are called casting agents and the
casting agents job is to help us find
the voice actors and they know all the
voice actors all over the world
and they say okay you want a voice that
kind of sounds like this I have just the
right person for you and they they help
us find them and those actors can
audition or sometimes if we know them
already then they just do it there's
some voice actors that do so many voices
you wouldn't even know that they were
the same person right Jorge oh yeah
another way to find them is when you
when you're watching movies and you hear
them speak you go oh they sound so
unique or so different and then you you
look around them you know an animation
we don't always want to use the same
people because then movie starts
sounding exactly the same so you also
want to find actors who've never done it
so that they're bringing a new sort of
flavor to the dish and then with with
kids you know kids grow up right so
their voices change so hiring kids to do
cartoon voices is incredibly unique
because you will always need to have
real kids to sound real no one can make
their voices sound like a like a real
kid so that's a very special sound and
I've been you know very lucky to have
been able to record kids in their first
movies so that's always awesome because
you know a lot of kids that are really
funny and do really funny voices at home
and then you get paid to do that
[Music]
okay so our next question
is from Eleanor who's ten from North
Hollywood California very close to where
I am right now Jorge what is your what
are some of your favorite animated films
I adore Henry Selick and Pemberton's The
Nightmare Before Christmas that is the
movie that made me want to go into
animation I also really loved spirit
away Miyazaki spirit away if you keeps
having seen that movie you should watch
it you're gonna love it and then the
first movie I saw in the theater when I
was little was in the 70s
I'm pretty much sure none of you were
born at this time but my dad took me to
see Pinocchio and the big screen and I'm
45 and I haven't recovered from that
experience it is freaking amazing and
then I'm just gonna admit it one of my
all-time favorite animated movies is the
book of life every time I watch it I get
to feel everything I felt making that
movie I get to visit all my friends all
those characters are so dear to me so I
I know it's not normal for people to
pick their own movies but I adore the
book of life I think that's wonderful
because you work so hard on it for so
many years and you probably love the
team that you work with so I think
that's a great thing for it I think it's
great to love your own work self self
love is a good thing some of my favorite
movies would be I like a lot of films I
saw when I was a kid like Bambi and you
know Snow White and then of course that
yeah Nightmare Before Christmas is huge
one you know I guess because maybe
around because we're about the same age
ish so that was a big one and I love
stop-motion so much I like to see a lot
of movies at film festivals when you get
older you could go to film festivals and
animation festivals and you can see
movies that you wouldn't see anywhere
else and they're usually shorter movies
so there's a lot of films I won't say
the names of them but there's a lot of
movies that are being made by artists
all over the world even as we speak that
I really love to see our next question
is from Madeline who's 13 and Marlowe
who's 9 and they're from Los Angeles
hardest thing for you to enemy or draw
anything in perspective I'm kind of more
of a I like flat things I like kind of
organic things I don't like having to do
things where I have to measure
everything and you know make things
something that's like super super
precise so I like more organic shapes
and more natural shapes than like having
to draw a car exactly the way the car
looks would be harder for me than
getting to draw kind of a cartoony
looking car you know what's really hard
to when people ask you to draw them
because I draw funny as you guys
hopefully saw I'm a cartoony guy so when
people ask me to draw them it's really
hard for me to not make fun of them and
my natural instinct is to do a funny
drawing of them but a lot of people
that's not what they want they don't
want you to make fun of them and they
certainly don't want you to make fun of
what they look like
so that's the worst when when you know
like an older lady or an older gentleman
or someone really serious finds out I'm
an artist and they go hey could you
could you draw me it makes me very
nervous and I have to hold back from
from making fun of them I actually love
it when people draw kind of unflattering
drawings of me I think it's just
hilarious it's good to have a thick skin
when you ask someone to join you our
next question is from Jayden who's 7
who's in Los Angeles California how long
will it take to do all of the drawings
for a short film but we don't have a
length on it so how long does it take to
do all the drawings for a film some
people can do a little short in one day
you know they can spend like four or
five hours doing it and then some people
like me I spent three years doing an
eight-minute short it could take a long
time and then some people can think even
longer than that so it all depends on
how complicated and how long your
animated shorts going to be what about
you Brooke how long did it take you to
do your you didn't academy award-winning
short movie girl
it took me it took me nine months to
draw it and a few more months to do
what's called post-production so drawing
it as
production of it and I just remember
sitting in my apartment
and I drew it on paper and just being
surrounded by as much paper on the floor
as I had in my in my stack of complete
drawings that I was happy with I had I
felt like I had just as many drawings
that I had to throw out because also I
was animating in pen
I didn't animate in pencil first so that
probably added to it but but it's you
know it's it's very gratifying like you
do a few drawings and then you and then
you test the drawings to see how they're
animating the way that Pete docter did
and the flip book and when you see them
come to life it gives you the energy to
keep going forward so it's a very it's a
tedious but exciting process all at the
same time our next question is from
Ramses who's 11 and Tijuana oh we have
some do you want to ask your question
what kind of things they'd get do you
guys get inspired to draw your
characters Oh inspiration that's a good
question first of all I grew up in
Tijuana
so be but before now for me my biggest
inspiration has always been where I'm
from and when I say where I'm from I
don't just mean you know I'm originally
from Mexico I mean my parents and my
family and all the stories that my
grandmother and my grandfather used to
tell me you guys talk to your talked to
your grandparents talk to your parents
they are full of stories ask them how
they met ask him about their first fight
after it ask them about the first time
they got in trouble
those are amazing stories so I always
say everybody has a book of stories in
their life and and it's all there so
that's been always my biggest
inspiration
how about you Brooke I love color I
don't know if you can see it but I'm
wearing I always wear a color wheel it's
a pin it's a little magnet actually and
it's a color wheel I love color so much
you can probably see a lot of color in
my room I'm very much affected by what
is known as pop culture or popular
culture so just cartoon characters and
fast-food mascots and you know just all
of the things that we see kind of in our
daily life that we
in jest I kind of you know I think an
artist job is to ingest the world as
they see it and then spit it out with
their their kind of fingerprint or their
flavor on that so I am inspired by music
I'm inspired by other people's films I'm
inspired by all of my friends and my
family and back straight all of those
kinds of things make it fun to sit down
and draw or think of a story or write a
story or draw a film that was a really
good question thank you so much and I'm
glad that we had we had people from all
sorts of places including Prudential
Jorge's hometown yeah our last question
is from Scout who's 8 and lipoma scout
do you want to ask your question or do
you want me to ask your question um yeah
so scout Scouts wonderful question is
what year did you get interested in
animating for me that would be the 70s
when I was a child my dad owned a model
train store which is like a toy store
but specializing in little toy trains
and I loved cartoons and we had a VHS
player and I would sit that's like way
before you know DVDs and streaming and
all that but I would sit and I would
watch different cartoons and I would
record them and I would cause them to
see how they were made
it was when I was a kid when I was
probably around your guyses age what
about you Jorge well you know everybody
animation we were all kids who drew and
the people who go into animation or
become artists are basically the kids
who don't stop drawing so when I was 13
or 14 my my dad and a big family dinner
you know this is very dramatic
he said Jorge what are you going to do
with your life and I said well Papa I
want to be a painter I want to be a
writer because I used to love stories I
mean used to love painting but also I
want to be a movie director and there's
a family friend that that dinner and he
said you know that is animation you get
the right stories you get to draw and
paint and you get to meet movies so my
father said no you could not do this and
and
and you know I was that kid of that when
his parents told him not to do stuff it
only wanted me to do it more so and
obviously my dad my dad's an architect
and he was very supportive but back then
he was not supportive he just you know
it just seemed like a crazy career cuz
personally I didn't see anybody that
looked like me making cartoons so the
times have changed now all people from
all parts of the world and boys and
girls it's it's really this is a field
that's opened up to everybody yeah when
I was little there weren't a lot of gals
animating but now there's every every
gender identification and every person
every any kind of person can come out
and tell their story
and those stories are being embraced now
more than ever so it's a wonderful time
to study animation and we hope that this
moment of you know talking to Jorge and
I and seeing all these different guests
today will inspire some of you to become
animators or artists or designers or
musicians or anything the arts are real
and they're a great field to be in
so that was our last question we wanted
to know if any of you have drawn
anything during this time period if any
of you or all of you would hold up your
drawings because we want to see your
artwork now that's amazing credible
stuff guys did a great job good job
everyone did this make you want to draw
more after this and and hopefully you
you guys have your parents next to you
and and your parents heard all this
stuff this is a real thing they you know
you can grow up and do for a living this
is something that you can you can follow
this path all of us every single artist
and and person you saw today they all
started out like little kids drawing
just like you're doing right now so
hopefully this is a path to a career
making cartoons and animation and and
never having to grow up yes
and for any of you who love animation
and you don't know how to draw you don't
love drawing there's all sorts of other
job
animation as well so when you're old
enough to start looking at that you can
work in production you become you can
become an editor there's all sorts of
things to earn ways to work in animation
I mean animation needs accountants too
so there's an animation so if you want
to work in an animation studio when
you're older that is a thing that you
can achieve thank you all so much thank
you for holding up your drawings thank
you for your questions we appreciate all
of you joining us today and we want to
thank Pete docter and all our friends at
Pixar and we want to thank Michael and
Griff chiquinho and we want to thank
Jerry Beck Mindy Johnson and Katelyn
Manocchio and we want to thank Howard
green and Peter Ramsey and Miguel hidan
and all our friends at Sony Pictures
animation and Henman Lee and our friends
at Walt Disney Animation Studios and
Kendall Cronkite and Priscilla Wong and
all our friends at Universal Pictures
and DreamWorks Animation and Pierre
coffin and our friends at illumination
and we also want to say a huge gigantic
thank you to the city of Los Angeles
Department of Cultural Affairs this
program was made possible in part by a
very generous grant from them thank you
thank you thank you thank you for for
joining us today we hope you had a great
time we totally did if you enjoyed the
program please share the link with all
your friends yep and don't forget you
can check out a lot of really cool
extras about animation on Oscars org you
just click events and then choose family
day the art of animation thank you so
much everyone for coming we had a great
time we hope you did too